the exhibition here at the Wallach is to
celebrate the one hundred and fiftieth
anniversary of the Woodlawn Cemetery in
the Bronx it's really special to be able
to see this several hundred acre site
through its development in its records
and its architectural and finer elements
brought here to a gallery space this was
something that is actually a rather rare
print and we found this within the
Woodlawn Cemetery archive the only other
one I was able to find online is at the
Library of Congress and it's a print
that catches the moment right before the
unification of where the consolidation
of the city into the five boroughs in
1898 this is the Bronx in 1897 in 2006
the cemetery gave its entire historic
archive to the Avery library at Columbia
University for the availability of
historic research into the monuments and
artworks that are at Woodlawn this is a
really exciting collaboration with the
woodlawn cemetery and Conservancy in
honor of their 150th anniversary as well
with Avery architectural fine arts
library here at Columbia who the Wallach
has long partnered with to do new
research and helped to present the deep
holdings that they have the cemetery was
very careful about the foundation of
each monument because of the weight of
the granite and also because of the
contents the human remains inside to
maintain a respectful monument for it so
they required a foundation water or a
request to add art or any other thing to
this particular law and this is where
you'll find the details of which artists
are working there the exhibition gives
us a wonderful opportunity to reflect on
the important history of woodlawn and
its relationship to the growth of new
york city as well as to think about all
that goes into creating the monuments in
the landscape and the architecture
Woodlawn